what year did you enlist in in in in the
uh when you went to the army right yeah
one yeah one so that was uh was that
right after bc it was so so 2000 bc came
out in 2000 yeah yeah so
you know kind of give it give us like a
how was your experience man like like
like it's a co1 and this is a september
11th happens yeah it's a hell of a time
in the army yeah it's right after
september 11th so um
pretty much um
you know that experience i mean
what can i say man like i at that time i
made a record it was um
it was the uh the situation stories that
was the album the album was you know it
was satire i've heard people say yo
satire it's true it was it was it was
just done to kind of like
um uh
like allegorically like make an album
that was
uh
you know just get under the skin you
know what i mean of folks that were
saying that
yo man i need the records to be hard i
want you to speak hard at the beach the
lyrics you know i want more and then and
then i gave him less
right by making a record like that and
the record was was strictly just
something that
it wasn't serious but it was like
something that it was it was it was
still palatable it was something that
was tangible you could have went out got
the artwork you look at it open the fold
out right you know who's this guy
wearing that shirt and yeah why is he
writing that and you know we paid 25
bands for the source ad you know to run
that
the
sources the source was scared to run the
ad because of the relationships that
they were saying could have been ruined
right
and they did it for the money of course
they did you know that's what i'm trying
to say so and then after that they turn
around and blackboard me further you
know what i mean so and took money you
know what i mean to like blackball me
right so you know you're talking about
that record was made like at the the way
i felt at that juncture was like you
know what
rapping it you know i'm still young
enough to go out and make a difference
and do something else that's right and
and and pretty much like
be a kaiju in a way for you know try to
do something good right but then of
course you know you make records
and you know you do a record like uh
and you do record like draft me and you
say a lot of crazy stuff on the record
and then you know you grow you get older
you see things
you know other people see things you you
you know you you become privy to certain
things and he's like man wow it's like
you know everywhere you turn you're
trying to make a difference trying to
make a change and uh
you kind of find yourself like adding on
to
some of the things that have made the
world more disconnected right because
before and after pictures tell you a lot
about you know what what
what how good something was right before
and after pictures right yep so that's
all really you got to do man that's my
answer how many how many years were you
in the service i mean you know got in
and over four is supposed to be two
right but got into 04 got in no one and
got out no four so and then you had did
you you went overseas
uh no that's not no you didn't you
didn't end up going over no i didn't do
that okay okay
yeah it's just an interesting experience
you know because it's like
i remember seeing that in
whatever magazine like oh [ __ ] cannabis
is in the i mean you know i mean i did i
did write doctrine for the strikers bro
like first brigade to have them
um you know i always was like a
getaway driver kind of guy and um even
though i was a scout 19 delta
um
you know i i i was i was on a three
truck man striker brigade wrote bro
doctor help write doctrine for those
vehicles
they perform and i did they definitely
used me to test them test the
performance